have you ever cheated
hi i'm shine reynolds and i'm still on
the lookout i've had some good dates i'm
liking my views that you know i'm saying
it's all good right now charm aren't ya
and i've had some bad dates how do you
think you've done on the date i don't
really give a [ __ ] i'm not gonna lie
about it where are all the decent men
not in my dms that's for sure you get me
i feel like i'm rolling with demand then
what's going on 35s it seems like a lot
of men don't know how to treat a lady
i'll just manhandle everything and this
guy's putting a chest and chest in the
napkin
will i have better luck this season what
would you do if my ex was after you he
can have you let's find out this
is grilling
i'm biggs i'm here to go on a nice date
i want to see what baby girls saying
after being on love island you must be
used to this kind of thing right i'm
more like a one-night stand man
but i thought let me come here and try
to change that i can handle a grill and
i'm ready i'm ready for anything
perfect should i be skilled
hello hello hello how are you i'm good
how are you good thank you i'm cheyenne
thanks nice to meet you she's a very
very fun girl
i've met him before
i feel like we've actually met before
we have briefly uh you actually gave me
your jacket mm-hmm
you want it back and i'm joking it's all
yours i can't believe she didn't bring
my jacket but you know what that means i
can get it tonight
tell me about you pigs i'm big okay i'm
29
i'm from scotland
obviously i did love island i invest in
property would you say you're a ladies
man yeah i would say so confident yeah
yeah yeah okay what's your type do you
like scottish girls or english girls oh
wow
i like both
well i prefer them english girls really
why is that i feel like we connect more
so what's your type um
you
what is your type you can't say me
he's cheeky his name
i like personality you like personality
yeah but you just said me i could be
like horrible are you telling me what i
want to hear
that i was you know what like
looks obviously but personality is my
main really like a funny girl hyper
active okay
yeah i'm big on personality vibes and
like you got to be
smart i like good deep conversations why
do you not have a man why do i not have
one i'm very picky why is everyone
asking i don't have a man obviously it's
why i'm dating them it's because i know
what i want and i find
not that many men can give me what i
want so what do you want then stability
honesty
loyalty
have you met a lot of guys have you been
on a lot of dates i've been unfair for
you nobody could get a second date with
me no
really yeah yeah
why do you say it's so surprised i don't
know if you're maybe being too picky
or
maybe being bougie
not
i'm not bougie i'm sure the guys you've
met were like decent guys listen
everyone seems decent when you go on a
first date because it's like putting
your best foot forward isn't it you know
but then turns out that the ladies men
that have so many women and
like to keep it with loads of options
that's the problem that i'm having
okay okay so they move a bit
mud yeah do you move mad you know what i
used to but i'm 29 ready to settle are
you
okay
i'm very big on like the relationship
goals and building with someone when was
your last relationship years ago like a
good few years ago really
yeah yeah because you're a beautiful
girl so i'm surprised like you haven't
thank you fine no the joy is it's
because i don't date for the sake of
like dating
so now i'm trying to actually date with
intentions what about you well like last
relationship
a couple of months ago actually what
you're like freshly single like six
months fresh yeah yeah
i never said so now i would like to save
us to pursue something with you would
that be a rebound now it by wooden so it
would i would treat it that way but if
you make it past that
then i know you're the one what do i
have to do to be the one okay cook
yeah
very clean
no no if you start listing these like am
i your mum my woman needs to cook clean
it's just my preference why am i
cleaning up after you i'm not your mum
can you cook can you clean yeah i can
i'd do all that okay see me if we're
like if we're together i'll be doing all
that okay so would you say your provider
yeah i would say so you say you're an
alpha yeah i'm definitely different from
yeah how different it's different most
guys would expect to go to like cooking
clean
you just asked me if i could cook and
clean but i just wanted to know if you
if you could okay get me so would it
actually be an issue if i couldn't cook
i'd find it weird so would that be a red
flag for you
yeah what else is a red flag i hate
girls i go clubbing too much
how much do you go clubbing so i'm sure
obviously if you've been on love island
and stuff you collab a lot now yes i've
done all that i'm done i'm finished how
do i know you're done like you could be
telling me you're done i'll prove it to
you i'm done well that build really
what'd you do last weekend
wait did you if you say clubbing um
i went clubbing okay
i didn't want to
i was there just to support my boy oh
yeah you didn't want to
that bad you ended up going clubbing i
didn't want this i was there to support
my boy he's just newly singles so like
in your lads group how many of you are
single truthfully yeah only two
how many is in your group like eight
okay
two single yeah and so you decide to cut
the single ones you don't want to just
you know yeah i just thought i need i
needed to help him help him or help
yourself did you pull
why are you starting no okay wait wait
hold up i feel like it's a police
investigation it's just more like i was
there to support him i didn't want to be
there but i thought you're my boy you're
newly single let me support okay so i
have to pull a girl just to support my
mind i'll do that how many women have
you slept with these questions are muds
go
on why are you getting shy or mr
confident a minute ago okay how many not
many how many of them eight
you only slept with eight women that's
really good i feel like you're lying no
no i mean it he's lying
do you really say great women so what's
your longest relationship
two years or about a year
my longest yeah like two three years
okay how did i end was that your fault
it was on my terms my still good friends
okay that's good i like that how about
you yeah we're still good friends for
sure are you
what's her side of the story definitely
but
that doesn't matter have you ever
cheated
yeah
why did i come here another tea
it's a you know what obviously i'm not
proud i did it that's why you're smiling
because i'm like i'm over all that i've
actually cheated on all my
what you've cheated
why did i tell her that so how many
relationships have you had maybe like
six hold on you slept with more than
eight people then no yes if you've had
six girlfriends and you've treated
wait wait hold up hold up wait wait wait
wait wait baby it's about you and me a
for effort is trying to maintain this
life definitely stick with a lot of
women then you've cheated on all your
girlfriends so would you call yourself a
high value man a high volume no
they wouldn't no you don't want to try
and run that flag ah respect myself but
you just don't respect women
i do but how can you if you cheat on
them it's just a drunken mistake
no did you that was in the past though
but it's now i'm looking to say oh
but do you think a woman's going to want
to settle for something like your track
record's not great is it exactly but you
know what i've done it all so i did that
i've done it again and again and again
yeah but that's in the past but i'm sure
you said that to your new girlfriend and
then it happens again history repeating
itself i did that it's in the past it's
done really how do i can trust you do
you not feel like you can trust me well
this is the thing and i feel like this
is why it would be hard because you've
got really friendly trustworthy eyes
yeah i feel you he's a bit of charmer
isn't he
if i then was with you
and then you cheated
all people would ever say to me is more
for you you know he's a cheater true
ain't going to happen this is wrong
you're a good guy
have you ever cheated no
be honest no never cheated no need to no
need to just break up them you're being
close no do you know what to be fair i
felt a detachment but just break up see
i wish i had that quality yeah
the thing is with me i like keeping
people happy so i don't do things for me
as in last week i went clubbing and they
wanna but i had to to support my friends
so you take no accountability for your
actions
not really no okay
am i being a bit mean
i'm clean now i'm clean do you believe
me i feel like you do no i want to
believe you but i'm not going to no no i
think you should do you have commitment
issues then i did before but not now i
could feel a connection i could actually
feel the vibe but
because i know that you're a cheater i'm
trying to like resist it she definitely
wants me i can tell i could feel the
connection i could i could have lied to
you but i told you the truth i'm done
but i feel like this is the typical you
know when you go back into like the
school girl bad boy oh he can change for
me no you're not going to change me no
but girls love that the girls do i'm a
woman so women the same
because growing up i was like the nice
boy and nice to get on so i thought you
know what let me become a [ __ ] and
then all these girls started coming what
happened what made you turn sour then
because nice guys to finish last do you
think it's true i don't think they do
now i like the quiet mysterious one in
the corner yeah i like a lot of girls i
like that yeah i really like the one
that no one else wants to talk to i'll
believe that don't have to i believe
like your exes were quite loud active no
no because i'm quite a loud
person and i'm very active so i need
someone to give me the balance and
bring me in so how many women have you
actually slept with and i feel like you
need to just tell the truth
like 16.
okay how many do you think
at least a hundred reason why reason why
i don't want to make a horrible
assumption but you went on love island
so when you come out i feel like
i was in a relationship
okay so do you feel like you've had
you're like people put it as like whole
years have you done that yeah i've done
that years ago so how many people do you
sleep with sixteen
how many have you slept with next
question
that means a lot if you're not answering
that yeah so what what if it was a lot
it's an ego thing with men
not a lot of guys want to go that
slipped before
why though it's an eagle thing i don't
want to walk into a club and like this
guy says i hate them
there's that there's that but at the
same time why is it nice for women to
experience that if i've walked into a
club of you but girls they don't really
care about that wait we actually know
but joy is it's because society's
conditioned us not to care as much yeah
yeah yeah don't make it such an issue
what would you care i wouldn't i
wouldn't and it depends on the woman
that you've done it with as well oh yeah
i wouldn't like it you wouldn't no
really there's no way my baby girl's
gonna be sleeping i don't hell not
more double standards
would you be with me if i slept with 50
men nah but i feel like you've slept
with definitely at least 50.
but so you have you're not delighted no
no i haven't but if i told you that you
wouldn't care because if you told me i
would ever taught a guy yeah that's
words
do you [ __ ] wifey's only like if you're
my girl that's about it but do you like
women giving you head
yeah you're angry
no i'm just saying nothing you know what
women they're more giving yeah and men
men are selfish yeah do you come quick
then
no why'd you say it's so defensive it's
a silly question no it's a question he
definitely comes quick how long did you
last 45 minutes
it's okay what would you like longer
no good little workout what about you
maybe 20.
that's fair
do you get a lot of meditation like
attention it's hard being a woman men
will just chat you up everywhere like
even when you have a face mask on
because
men were chatting us up like you can't
even see my face do you like it though
no i do i don't i actually don't always
i like when you were younger growing up
no not too far because i was i was
actually really ugly growing up
yeah i was probably ugly when did it all
change i think when it was like year
nine when i got boobs and learned to put
makeup on then the boys in school were
like when my friends started seeing me
different because it was like i used to
like be gold they used to like make me
go and go be the goalkeeper
and then it was just a point when they'd
be like oh shine you look nice today
goalkeeper
painful that
[Laughter]
how was it growing up in scotland
obviously i was born in holland so i
moved to scotland when i was 12. oh
really yeah we were like the only black
folks yes so how was that for you
it was weird
obviously i'm used to being around my
own people but i made me learn a lot you
get me like growing up with white folks
and then yeah because back home like in
holland it was just black people
everywhere so as an adult in your life
did you date black or white women
because obviously if you're in an
area that an environment that's
predominantly white people yes mainly
being white i've never dated a black
girl what or even kissed a black girl
never even kissed i would like to in
scotland if there is a black girl there
most of my boys are white in it so when
i
the black girl will automatically go for
my boy yeah and the white girl would go
for me
where's your family and stuff how do
they i know it sounds bad and it's gonna
sound really mad but how do they feel
about like you dating white girls
they're fine they're happy like like
whereas stays mainly white folks so yeah
but do you ever further away do you ever
like get panicky like going with a woman
that's white because you know like
everything's fine until christmas comes
and the racist joke comes out the girl
said they aren't really like do not like
that at all oh really that's good yeah i
think then you're fetishized for being a
black guy like how do you know
everyone's not just going with you
because you're the black experience
i don't even
i won't even know she'll say something
by
it's just the tone and the text that
they use because if they happen to
mention your color then it's like a
fetishizing you know what i'm gonna say
a mad thing you've probably never had
but i feel like most of my exes they've
never even been with a black guy
weirdly i prefer that
i don't know why so but then do you not
see how like you could be like the fish
well they're juggling like love is love
yeah yeah literally attracted to anyone
and everyone i've dated white guys so
i'm not saying that but do you not find
it weird that if you're their first
experience that you're just like a
fetish or an experience to them
nah no i i can understand
but it's that's not been the case for me
okay when was the last time you cried
long time ago how long's long time easy
six seven years what yeah yeah my gran
died
i don't cry now
you don't have to see black black guys i
know that's what i mean i know men don't
like show emotion but i didn't realize
it was like that
mad
like i swear everyone i've spoken to
doesn't cry i feel like life could have
been worse so anything that happens you
just need to keep going you're just like
chill let's say we're going out
and you keep clubbing or go out every
night
i won't complain to you
you get me it's just me i just keep it
in because i feel like it's it's in my
it's not in me to like complain to a you
get me but like communication is key so
then when we break up so you're going to
get mad at me
and then dish me some insults are you
going out on time yeah so i wouldn't
even i just wouldn't complain i was just
like
end the relationship that's really bad
you wouldn't even tell a woman what
she's not that's actually really
horrible so you just would end it out
nice and clean
but it's not it's not complaining it's
just expressing to your partner what you
do and don't want it's about
understanding each other like no one's
perfect you're not going to just get
with me and we're going to know how we
work or what we want and what we like
yeah i would say that's like real toxic
drink yeah big but that's a good thing
to think but i don't want to complain
about it don't want you just break and
leave me then i'm heartbroken so how how
is that good i know and i feel you i
feel you have you done that yeah i've
done it so many times so there'll be
fine skills too i won't say much i'll
just that's actually really horrible
like genuinely and i mean in the nicest
way to use i don't mean to disrespect
you but there's nothing worse as a
female than when a man just ghosts us
for no reason because we can be insecure
and for someone to just disappear out of
nowhere not tell us or whatever that's
really not cool man i feel you i feel
you what can i say it's grilling
did you feel me but you're not going to
change your life i'm learning not think
about i'm not doing it on purpose it's
like i don't want to complain i don't
want to tell you don't go out but just
like
but that's way worse than the woman feel
like she's not enough yeah yeah
this girl needs to relax you get me
relax
sounds like someone's running from their
issues
but remember i'm not doing this on
purpose yeah but it's not nice whether
you're doing it on purpose or not like
it doesn't always have to be intentional
that's not nice like this is like real
emotions like this is real women how we
feel you know so how many women have you
ghosted quite a few exactly so you're
not aware because you won't keep doing
that yeah i mean now i'm aware she is on
one i don't think that's a bad trait you
know what i've got
that is a bad trait that's a big red
flag it's not like a evil thing because
i don't want to argue
but just because you're not
intentionally being horrible doesn't
mean it's not a bad thing that's what
you need to understand
now you got me there
cheers you got me there kissed you
learning and growth yeah thank you
that's why that's why you're you're
you're here with me
yeah yeah yeah would you yeah would you
go i would would you go back there with
the next thing
why not
say if we're together because you
actually would i could never be with you
because you're going to go back with
your ex no not like that no i mean like
let's say we broke up and she was there
available
and my heart was feeling it
it's not something i've done before but
it's possible you definitely think you
have done before
i promise you do you think there's the
one that got away um yeah actually um is
there one that got away
nah
you know what see all my actually they
were good girls it's just me being
immature whatever
but it's a blessing everything happens
for the reason i won't call cheating a
blessing but okay
so what i'd want to see actually the is
the lads group chat that's where the
gossip actually is yeah
do you know what maine's dead yeah yeah
not like he used to be well what did you
be like just wild with your girlfriends
no no not girlfriends
or any other girls do you like do men
compare pics and stuff
like a prediction yeah
do you girls do that type of thing you'd
send the nude to your friend before you
send it to the guy talking to you
because you'd be like is this a girl
okay okay so do you say nudes no i don't
i'm just saying but have you ever no i
think i sent one once and then instantly
regret it this girl definitely says
nudes i feel like it's normal
for me personally it's not something
i've asked for i know a lot of guys that
do it but that doesn't do anything for
me yeah
so have you always been a good girl then
because i'm not a good girl i think i
could be wrong i feel like you're father
crazy yeah you've been a bit active in
the past but you're over there you're
like me this is why we are here
i wish i'm a good girl definitely not
i'm quite uptight when it comes to like
ben and dayton always or just recent i
think women we have issues because it's
like men always have an ulterior motive
they can't just want to hang out it's
always because they're trying to sleep
with us that's one thing i'm definitely
from guys like that what would you
straight up just saying
no
you're not i like chilling i like
children
you're like the dangerous kind that will
chill have it all children up and leave
like that's why i'm not i mean like even
if we let's say tonight even if we
didn't have sex whatever right
we're chilling i like chilling again it
doesn't have to be like that
you might not believe what i'm saying
but trust me yeah and that's what
happens ladies then we let the guard
down
and then it's just gone wrong yeah yeah
yeah now i do feel you
yeah i fight around you often no that's
all i'm counting
how soon into the relationship i'll
thought straight away would you are you
like that yeah because i just would just
be comfortable in it just i'm not trying
to like put on this fake image on
perfect no yeah okay white flag if
that's even a thing i love a girl
comfortable so if you fight even right
now i'd probably kiss you
just for that
legit because you're comfortable without
me that that means a lot
the girl got a fart girl got a fart
would you be with me if i had only fans
it's a sticky one that what
i couldn't not not for me why not only
phones ah
nah would you be with me if i had it i
don't the way i see industries and stuff
i don't really mind
i'm not saying only friends a bad bad
thing but like i've worked too hard to
be like
going out with someone that does that
but do you not think sometimes like
they're smart they're smart women it's
not as just simple as taking a pic like
it's marketing yourself
pictures consistency okay can i take a
girl home to my family and tell her what
she does only fun i don't know can you i
could could you
it's not about what someone does you
don't lead with that then today because
there's women that are smart kind caring
like compassionate women so why should
you lead without because she does this
for a living no so you'd be with me if i
did that
yeah but if you're a nice guy you
treated people with respect like you're
a nice person why should your job define
you what really annoys me is why can't
he have the same energy for trappers
like it's just women hustling and making
their money i feel like most people
would agree with me like
people would rather someone be with a
trapper than be with someone that works
in the adult industry and what's sad
about is the reality of a trapper like
they ruin a lot of lives facts but it's
an eagle thing like i can't be with a
girl
and everyone's seen her body like what
kind of man does i make me what's mine
is mine so i don't want to share
what's mine with everyone i'd want to be
like the laughingstock in that sense
okay we'll agree to disagree on this
what would you do if i slept with two of
your friends i'd be pissed off you know
i could feel the anger
i wouldn't would you not what if we're
in love nah
maybe you
[Laughter]
sweet daughter no i thought i couldn't
really what do you mean before yeah like
not now we're not asking to give it
before in the past i couldn't
could you no i couldn't actually yeah
nah
two of my friends will never go near my
girl ever what would you do if my ex was
after you i'll slap him would you
why why would he be like tonight enjoy
when those x's don't let you move on i
hate those types you know can i be
honest i actually pushed me off the go
really yeah if i know you've got crazy
eggs i'll burn my beautiful car
he can have you oh i don't want to go
through the stress man yeah
not you like you i'll go through the
stress but anyone else is his move
what if i got pro in prison for two
years would you wait
two years in prison i'm gone okay i'm
there but i'm gone
yeah i'd be would you would you let me
cheat in between no
so you expect me just to be right or die
could you be be honest yeah if i went to
gym 100 if i loved you i could easily
wait yeah i i believe you yeah i could
easily i believe you i think she's
calmed down a bit now what if i wanted
to involve other people in our sex life
okay at a start
but if it's like four years in that's a
bit weird
i think four years is when you start
doing another goal forever in it bring
them but another guy is a bit different
who's choosing you can yeah i think i
think if you were to i'm not saying that
i do yeah but i think if we were going
to
the woman would have to choose yeah
because otherwise you're asking for
drama yeah not fair and i'm easy pick as
many as you want
have you ever had freeson yeah and i
have have you have you
no
i know where you're lying
i can tell you about baby girl already
why i can tell you that cute
um
she's lying she's hundred percent out of
the freezer what if i was in the gang oh
that's weird like ganga yeah gang life
nah i'm not into that are you into that
girls love that
so there's a cert there's a certain
type of woman that likes that lifestyle
but i can assure you
many women do not love her no women like
lifestyle women like money they like
things they genuine so if you were a
rich
broker
they'll still love it it's just money
and lifestyle it's not that you're a
trapper okay it's just trappers because
joey is i think and this is just my only
analysis of him
women like trappers simply because
they're kind of you're quite they're
quite careless with their money and
stuff and like there's no structure
to the lifestyle whereas if you get with
a man that's got a good career and has
money it's a very different lifestyle
set up because it's so would you date me
if i was a drug dealer no no way you
wouldn't no way have you ever yeah i did
like when i was younger yeah never again
because i think it's wrong it's immoral
and there's plenty of other ways to get
money well you get different types i
don't condone it obviously but you get
definitely kind of you get the
immature one but you get some big boys
you know like they move correct but they
live that life tearing people's lives
apart yeah you're not into it
i feel you
so how do you think you've done fairly
well you've done it right i feel like it
was
easy it was easy a few red flags
yeah a lot of red flags you know what
the thing is a lot of red flags that i
put out there well you taught me you get
me how to fix these things why are you
actually going to do that for sure would
you go on another date i would actually
do you want to go another date easy yeah
which is tonight let's do it
i was i really enjoyed myself had a good
time i had a really good time the date
was beautiful i felt that's the
connection there
i was a bit nervous meeting her but it
went well
i don't know what i don't know if i'm
going to see him again i want to see him
again i just can't get past the cheating
would you see her again
easy
easy
and i think she would
he took it really well i feel like he
wasn't triggered and he just answered
correct but i felt like he was telling
me what i wanted to hear but i handed it
well
i think i fumbled a little bit she
caught me out but you know what i'm here
to learn you know i really really felt
like my vibes were i want to give them a
high score but i actually can't get past
the cheat in
so i'm going to give him an
eye
yeah i think i'm going to give biggs a
7.
you